did you see him
i saw a oneness
the unity of things
i was a plant
and an ant no but did you see him
i saw that there is love
and we are all a part of that love like
that you mean no
an old man with a beard
i mean he shimmers
and when he speaks his voice booms like
thunder i didn't see that
i saw shining light yes an old man and
his heart pours forth light
no
just light
but i saw love
and i see your love for god
and for me
which i never saw before
and i have disrespected it
perhaps
we are each guilty of that we are
fighters perhaps that hides the truth of
us both at times
they love god
my people
you showed me that
thank you
but their thinking should not be
controlled by these ancient terrors
there's a modern world archie your
church could be part of it
god wants me to serve you it's strange
and at times inexplicable together we
would be formidable
we could be the grit that makes the
pearl for each other
and i need you
you know them
and you truly love them
i will not kill you
you have seen the light
even if not god
now
how do we get rid of this crocodile
you must have had a plan
i had faith god would provide one when
the time came not really a plan though
is it
[Music]